ja was mich aufregt ist unserer
gesellschaft die besteht doch nicht nur
aus lauter diskriminierung eine offene
liberale gesellschaft die etwas anderes
als eine ansammlung von communitys die
ansprüche erheben die für ihre gruppen
quoten fordern das führt nicht in eine
moderne liberale gesellschaft das ist
ständegesellschaft und insofern wir
müssen viel tun für integration für
bildungschancen aber am ende kommt es
immer noch auf jeden und jeder einzelne
an sich auf anzustrengen und ich finde
den müssen wir entgegentreten wenn
irgendwie communitys aufrufen zu
bewusstem widerstand wie beim
integrationsgipfel im kanzleramt
denn läuft verschieben
sie sind gegen quoten interpretiere ich
das richtig
das finde ich ja sozusagen wie das
werfen eines steins aus dem glashaus die
er sich selber haben dass ich jetzt aber
nicht das originellste sprachlich
gebildet was meine versehen da war sie
also jetzt ernsthaft sie haben selber
ihr amt verloren als generalsekretärin
der fdp frau suding wird demnächst
ausscheiden als stellvertretender
vorsitzender wenn ich das richtig
gezählt haben sind im präsidium der
partei unter zwölf mitglieder noch drei
frauen würde man sich da nicht
vielleicht eine quote und sei es auch
nur vorübergehend für drei vier jahre
wünschen um das mal ein bisschen in
bewegung zu sein aber wenn ich das
einmal sagen dass das ist doch dann
eigentlich nicht schmeißen stein mit
glashaus sondern gerade nicht sondern
dann besonders ehren wert und
glaubwürdig dagegen zu sein wenn man
selber die unterstellung davon betroffen
ist deswegen ja los weniger
karrierechancen und bundestagswahlen wir
diese logik weiter führen dass das immer
gruppen merkmale von menschen dafür
ausschlaggebend sind wie man jetzt
irgendetwas quotiert wer wo sitzen soll
ob im öffentlichen dienst ob im
parlament dann können wir demnächst
statistische bundesamt erheben lassen
welche merkmale in der bevölkerung in
welchem prozentsatz vorhanden sind wir
brauchen gar nicht mehr wählen wenn man
das wirklich konsequenz der denk mir
geht es ums menschenbild dass wir davon
ausgehen dass wir individuen haben die
rechte haben und die chancen haben und
die sich selber bewerben um positionen
die was tun und dann andere menschen
überzeugen und nicht dass wir alles
quotieren für alles ansprüche erheben
das ist so ein grund sache die die
gerade schief läuft wir sollten nicht
alles quotieren ich finde aber dass die
frauenquote in der politik richtig war
die hat etwas bewegt und ich finde auch
eine frauenquote in aufsichtsräten und
vorständen von unternehmen richtig da
ist noch einiges zu tun und ansonsten
bin ich nicht für quoten muss ich ihnen
klar sagen irgendwann wenn man
vielleicht männerquote
verbote also was ich gut dessen symptome
für eine haltung also wir sind ja
inzwischen finde ich eine hoch spannende
debatte bei ganz anderen debatten über
merkmale über die man menschen
eigentlich nicht definieren sollten wir
haben auch neulich in der sendung
darüber gesprochen ich glaube es die
berliner humboldt-universität bei der
man sich jetzt nicht mehr als weißer
bewerben soll auf eine bestimmte
position sondern nur als person of color
ich frag mich und ich frag mich ob das
was miteinander zu tun hat ja auf diese
einordnung vermessen das miteinander zu
tun hat und ich stelle jedoch eine frage
letzte frage vielleicht angenommen wir
haben quoten egal ob frauenquoten oder
quoten verweise oder nicht weiß wer sagt
denn eigentlich den anderen dass sie
sich nicht mehr bewerben doch ich frage
mich beim thema frauenquote endlich wer
sagt eigentlich den fünfjährigen jungs
von heute oder den sechsjährigen jungs
was auf konstantin oder kevin du gehst
denn eine zukunft
in der du vielleicht nicht mehr genommen
wirst weil du ein junge bist also
schnell man immer gewesen eine zukunft
in der deine hautfarbe oder geschlecht
eine rolle spielt wobei nicht weg
wollten und deswegen wie die auch immer
konsequent gegen jegliche quote gramm
argumentieren egal ob in der politik und
vorständen zu sagen da gibt es noch viel
zu tun finde ich ganz schlimm wir dann
tut es fiel dann fördert frauen des
films muss doch möglich sein es gibt
bestimmt genauso viele frauen wie männer
das bzw wir haben einfach nicht wir
haben schon 1000 toten an die wir uns
historisch längst gewöhnt haben redet
kein mensch mehr darüber beispielsweise
haben betriebsräte eine quote in
aufsichtsräten sonst alles mit einem
fall weiter schlimm die kommen von der
gewerkschaft die haben eine
minderheitsposition da geht das doch
nicht nur das äußere ja auch weil ich
rede jetzt
zum beispiel regel von frauen in
vorständen und aufsichtsräten klar aber
dann muss man eben mut zu
kampfkandidaturen haben das eine ganz
andere frage rot sie hoffen eine
kampfkandidatur in einem aufsichtsrat
wenn sie sie waren per einholen
das ist genau der andere will ich gar
nicht im sport oder im fußball gibt es
wenn es mal nicht so läuft mit dem ziel
zu gewinnen eine taktische methode die
lautet mit der brechstange und ich bin
manchmal schon geneigt ich bin
eigentlich auch nicht für für quoten
aber jetzt doktern frauen und wir alle
seit jahrzehnten daran rum dass es zu
einem eklat kommt und es hat einfach
nicht hin grauen dann fände ich durchaus
lohnenswert und nachdenken ob man nicht
sich fünf bis zehn jahre gönnt wobei es
mit der brechstange nämlich mit einer
quote schafft und dann entspannt man
sich wieder und hat ekel ist nun um die
methoden air berlin geht es um dieses
menschenbild dass wir mehr darüber
diskutieren wie geht es um das hinten
gruppen merkmal übersehen als sie was
macht jemand oder was sagt jemand das
ist sozusagen das ist aber das ist ja
auch erklärung es geht um das argument
um die qualität des arguments oder der
arbeit und nicht um die position des
jähnigen der grad wasser setzte man sich
eben quotierte gruppe automatisch dem
verdacht aus nur in diese position
gekommen zu sein aufgrund einer quote
und ist und ist richtig und hatte das
team in die reihe das heißt der trauer
und der position aber es geht doch eben
entweder im chancen oder mehr geben sie
reichern das ist absolut aber ich
liberaler aber ich glaube dass sozusagen
noch mal ich sehe ist er in einer auf
der zeitachse um etwas wenn es jetzt
mein intensiv das ziel die mittel auch
hier nicht ja da bin ich anderer meinung
ich glaube da wir sehen sie es bei
anderen themen wie sehen sie eine
migrantenquote im öffentlichen dienst da
würde ich sagen wenn man das in betracht
zieht dann soll man konsequent sein dann
hätte ich gerne eltern quote in der
regierung und nicht lauter kinderlose
minister woher auch dann muss man aber
irgendwann war dann fragen sie an glaube
dass sozusagen jetzt gerade der
klassische fehler passiert das wenn man
eine diskussion über begannen mit
frauenquoten für plötzlich alles mit
allem zusammen das hat er wieder alles
mit allem zusammen das werden wir nicht
schaffen mein petitum wäre ein ziel das
ziel ist wichtiger als die methode einem
dann das habe ich noch nie deshalb
konnte er nie richtig verstanden dass
das frauen da abstand davon nehmen so zu
sagen ich will doch da rein ich will da
rein wie gerhard schröder beim
kanzleramt ich will da rein und jetzt
gibt es möglicherweise die chance auf
eine quote dann nutze ich die dann bin
ich drin und dann verbessere ich die
welt die atmosphäre das zusammenleben
den aufsichtsrat keine ahnung weshalb
das hat mich nie richtig überzeugt aber
vielleicht gelingt ich bin um das klar
zu machen außerhalb der frauenquote für
keine andere quote auch für mängel an da
nicht von front weil ich habe davon
geredet weil sie reden ja allgemein von
quoten und aber muss man gleich
einschränken dazufügen das was die
grünen mit ihrer kanzlerkandidatin
gemacht haben oder was da passiert ist
ist ein gewichtiges gegenargument das
musterbeispiel gegen konkurrent red und
exakt am ente denn die partei der
basisdemokratie hat es den beiden
vorsitzenden überlassen zu entscheiden
weder kanzlerkandidat wird da waren die
zu zweit sonst hat sich keiner mehr
dafür interessiert dann saßen an zu mann
und frau nebeneinander oder gegenüber
und dann sagt die frau ich möchte aber
gerne und da die erste stelle auf den
grünen listen immer eine frau hat war
die sache entschieden und habe konnte zu
gucken das werden die später nach der
wahl noch mal diskutieren denn es war
ein riesenfehler der havag wer der
bessere kandidat war durchaus auch
argumentieren dass unfähigkeit sich in
der politik auch schon durchgesetzt hat
ohne dass die quoten radiologischer lag
also ist braucht nicht aber bedingt es
braucht nicht unbedingt diesen
mechanismus oder und deswegen finde ich
einmal ganz erstaunlich wenn so nach
diskussion auch gestern nach dem trial
wenn das wenn links twitter oder waren
die selbst erklärten feministen dort
dann ganz randale machen weil gott was
frau berbalk für hartz iv bekommt das
muss ja frauenhass sein sie war
offensichtlich die bessere kandidatin da
und warum schneidet sich so schlecht ab
in umfragen ist frauenhass das findet
dermaßen lächerlich und peinlich und
dann bin auch eine frauen wird mini
diesem kollektivistischen zwängen und
erwerbungen es dann überraschend gut
abgeschnitten
die auch aber trotzdem diese frauen
zählen das so alles was gegen freiberg
passiert ist automatisch frauenhass und
ganz von dieser gedanke zur quote den
klaus gerade gesagt hat eltern quote in
der regierung muss ich sagen nachdem was
wir jetzt mit corona und dem was kindern
dort angetan wurden von einer hat aber
auch kein von einer nahezu kinderlosen
regierung finde ich jetzt zumindest mal
spannenden gedanken dann fangen wir an
kinder zu machen das wäre eine
interessante auf halt ich bin auch gern
gesehen wenn sozusagen eine neue
regierungschef aufgefordert ist bei
männern und frauen darauf zu achten und
darauf zu achten dass auch der
kulturelle hintergrund mit eine rolle
spielt dann soll er oder sie doch bitte
auch darauf achten dass eltern in der
regierung sass gewinnen dann dann meinen
wir es ernst meinen dann ist das auch
kinder und ich glaube vor allem wenn wir
über eine eltern quote und damit kinder
auch wenn das jetzt ein bisschen
utopisch kinder im kanzleramt ich muss
sagen für mich wäre das nach ich weiss
nicht wie vielen jahren ich glaube das
letzte mal muss es ja unter dem frühen
helmut kohl gewesen sein dass im
kanzleramt eine familie war die gewusst
hatte und wie geht's eigentlich in
diesem land nie ganz nah jah sondern
wenn li na und das wäre ich muss sagen
ich bin immer wieder irgendwie berührt
davon egal wer regiert im weißen haus
wenn man diese familien mit kindern dort
einziehen sieht bei denen man weiß die
machen das hat nicht nur für sich
sondern die sehen jeden tag um wen es
eigentlich geht total spannendes thema
diabetes wir hätten schon seit 20 jahren
ernsthaft die diskussion über das elend
an den schulen das wäre ganz sicher aber
es erlebt ja keiner von denen
[Musik]